black holes are one of the strangest
things in existence they don't seem to
make any sense at all where do they come
from
and what happens if you fall into one
stars are incredibly massive collections
of mostly hydrogen atoms that collapse
from enormous gas clouds under their own
gravity in their core nuclear fusion
crushes hydrogen atoms into helium
releasing a tremendous amount of energy
this energy in the form of radiation
pushes against gravity maintaining a
delicate balance between the two forces
as long as there is fusion in the core a
star remains stable enough but four
stars with way more mass than our own
Sun the heat and pressure at the core
allow them to fuse heavier elements
until they reach iron unlike all the
elements that went before the fusion
process that creates iron doesn't
generate any energy iron builds up at
the center of the star until it reaches
a critical amount and the balance
between radiation and gravity is
suddenly broken the core collapses
within a fraction of a second the star
implodes moving at about a quarter of
the speed of light feeding even more
mass into the core it's at this very
moment that all the heavier elements in
the universe are created as the star
dies in a supernova explosion this
produces either a neutron star or if the
star is massive enough the entire mass
of the core collapses into a black hole
if you looked at a black hole what you'd
really be seeing is the event horizon
anything that crosses the event horizon
needs to be traveling faster than the
speed of light to escape in other words
it's impossible so we just see a black
sphere reflecting nothing but if the
event horizon is the black part what is
the whole part of the black hole the
singularity we're not sure what it is
exactly a singularity may be infinitely
dense meaning all its mass is
concentrated into a single point in
space with no surface or volumen or
something completely different
now we just don't know it's like a
dividing by zero error by the way black
holes do not suck things up like a
vacuum cleaner if we were to swap the
Sun for an equally massive black hole
nothing much would change for Earth
except that we would freeze to death of
course what would happen to you if you
fell into a black hole the experience of
time is different around black holes
from the outside you seem to slow down
as you approach the event horizon so
time passes slower for you at some point
you would appear to freeze in time
slowly turn red then disappear while
from your perspective you can watch the
rest of the universe in fast-forward
kind of like seeing into the future
right now we don't know what happens
next but we think it could be one of two
things one you die a quick death a black
hole curved space so much that once you
cross the event horizon there is only
one possible direction you can take this
literally inside the event horizon you
can only go in one direction it's like
being in a ready tight Annie that closes
behind you after each step the mass of a
black hole is so concentrated at some
point even tiny distances of a few
centimeters would mean that gravity acts
with millions of times more force on
different parts of your body your cells
get torn apart as your body stretches
more and more until you're a hot stream
of plasma 1 @ & white 2 you die a very
quick death very soon after you cross
the event horizon you would hit a
firewall and be terminated in an instant
neither of these options are particular
Pleasant how soon you would die depends
on the mass of the black hole a smaller
black hole would kill you before you
even entered its event horizon while you
probably could travel inside a
supermassive black hole for quite a
while as a rule of thumb the further
away from the singularity you are the
longer you live black holes come in
different sizes
there are stellar-mass black holes with
a few times the mass of the Sun and the
diameter of an asteroid and then there
are these supermassive black holes which
are found at the heart of every galaxy
and have been feeding for billions of
years currently the largest supermassive
black hole known is s500 1/4
eight 140 billion times the mass of our
Sun it is two hundred and thirty six
point seven billion kilometers in
diameter which is forty seven times the
distance from the Sun to Pluto as
powerful as black holes are they will
eventually evaporate through a process
called Hawking radiation to understand
how this works we have to look at empty
space empty space is not really empty
but filled with virtual particles
popping into existence and the
Nominating each other again
when this happens right on the edge of a
black hole one of the virtual particles
will be drawn into the black hole and
the other will escape and become a real
particle so the black hole is losing
energy
this happens incredibly slowly at first
and gets faster as the black hole
becomes smaller when it arrives at the
mass of a large asteroid it's radiating
at room temperature when it has the mass
of a mountain it radiates with about the
heat of our Sun and in the last second
of its life the black hole radiates away
with the energy of billions of nuclear
bombs and a huge explosion but this
process is incredibly slow the biggest
black holes we know might take up to a
googol years to evaporate this is so
long that when the last black hole
radiates away nobody will be around to
witness it the universe will have become
uninhabitable long before then this is
not the end of our story there are loads
more interesting ideas about black holes
we'll explore them in part two a big
thanks to Fraser Cain for help with this
video by the way we've made some cuts
without wallpapers in 4k four different
screen sizes you can get them on our
patreon page which also helps us to make
more videos like this December the first
month ever with three videos
you